hello everyone welcome back
for a brand new episode of the witching
hour
you know me you know haley but right now
we are talking
to the filmmakers behind save yourselves
alex
h fisher and eleanor wilson how are you
guys doing
we're doing great thanks for having us
thank you thank you for joining
us we're very very excited to have you
here
um just so our viewers and
uh our listeners get to know you guys a
little bit more i kind of wanted to go
back to the beginning at least to start
here and i was wondering
what kind of films were the two of you
watching when you were growing up and
do you find that they have influenced
what you tend to gravitate towards as
creators now
yeah tommy boy i never saw tommy boy
alex show she's still never seen it
watching it yeah but it was so weird i
don't know about this
weird black and white vhs copy that we
got from kentucky and it was like
it was black and white it wasn't the
same but all she saw was like little
tommy running
behind the bus and saying holy schnikeys
and she was like i'm out
and i was like no you've got it it is it
is weird that that
wasn't a movie that i saw growing up
because like there was
many many others my brother had an
amazing vhs
collection and we definitely watched a
lot of paulie shore
yeah yeah a lot of those ventura yeah
high concept silly comedies and that's
kind of what we've been
gravitating towards again lately yes
just like revisiting all those things
drop dead fred was a
big favorite growing up which i hadn't
seen until recently and also
um um yahoo serious movies which were
new to me as well do you guys know yahoo
serious
i do not know that alien oh my god
australian filmmaker who does these
three um
really big uh silly comedies they're
beautiful young einstein
is his first one which i think is the
best and yeah it's
it's a great watch they're spectacular
we just sort of wrote an essay about him
yeah you just saw a
drop dead fred for the first time as an
adult
yeah yeah what was that like
it was fantastic i was like oh this
movie yeah this movie's great it's like
uh
i don't know when you're a kid you
probably miss like the subtext maybe
like you're like you just think about
the
the silly you know the character in the
head or whatever and then
so i was watching and i was like what a
beautiful metaphor about mental health
yeah i was impressed with that
it's such a good word have you seen it
as an adult
yeah no i had imagined it wouldn't hold
up at all but i think you've inspired me
yeah you should watch it again it's
really fun and
really touching yeah yeah yeah and like
dirty dancing we watched like
we've been watching a bunch of old like
older movies because it's really sad
all the time so so we just like we were
watching with dirty dancing is like
just a beautiful an important film i had
no idea perfect movie i
had watched it a bunch of you know
growing up and then didn't realize that
it was about abortion rights
yeah and like you know using your
privilege for you know all this all the
stuff that like we care about now just
doing
all that in 1980 whatever yeah
you guys are uh you're keeping busy over
there with some good stuff i like this i
like this
filmography you're going through here
we're doing the important work
but it is what about what about for you
two
as creators together i'm i'm
like when when did you realize that your
sensibilities kind of like clicked
and balanced in a way that you can
actually make a feature film together
i mean i think a lot of that just comes
from the types of movies that we like
right you know like if you're aligned on
the thing
you know and liking movies together you
kind of know that you're going to be
aligned on on making a movie and i i
a lot of like our early courtship was um
i was watching movies obviously you know
we we live in new york and we go to the
nighthawk a lot and
um we saw carol together on one of our
first dates
yeah uh but the yeah i think
just sort of watching movies and then
talking about them afterwards and
realizing that we had
really very similar feelings about
everything
um kind of made it seem like okay we're
pretty aligned we could probably do this
together
i was really complimented early in uh
the
the dating when eleanor was like do you
want to watch the oscars with me because
i think you'd be fun to watch them with
like that because we would like make
yeah you didn't make fun of the same
like make fun of the same stupid same
stupid things yeah and i was like oh
that means
that means a lot
how did you go from like knowing that
you guys had like compatible movie
tastes
and could do it together too actually
landing on
what you wanted that first film to be
uh it was really the the film idea that
came first i mean we weren't like
looking for a project together or
anything it was just that
i had this idea which was just you know
really just the basic premise of like
couple goes upstate turn off their
phones aliens attack
and i told that to alex and he thought
it was funny and i was like that's a
perfect
it's just like a perfect metaphor i was
like this this uh
new york couple is like oblivious to the
world ending and they don't know what to
do when it happens
great just how we live our lives make a
lot of jokes about that yeah but um
but yeah and i guess the other thing was
that we had
um we had worked together in other
capacities we you know both had
different kinds of gig jobs that we did
yeah freelance stuff we
hired each other like eleanor was like
producing a lot of stuff i was shooting
and editing so we'd hire each other and
we like we got along even even like
during the parts of the
relationship where it was like a rocky
start it was very elegant
like well do you want to shoot this
documentary in iceland and i was like
yeah great
so we had traveled a lot and and worked
a lot together
closely on in particular on like very
small
crew type situation yeah it made just
the two of us either sometimes yeah so
like both shooting and yeah yeah so that
kind of i think gave us
i guess the confidence to be like we've
we've been in situations where we
spend a lot of time together and we're
working together and going
home together and it's like okay well we
can probably
we can probably do this we did a big
project get sick of each other yeah we
did a big project where we traveled
around the country
making these little documentaries about
urban parks and that
like on that travel job it was mostly
the two of us sometimes we had a third
a dp and that's where we started writing
down notes for the idea it's like
eleanor had the idea and then we just
write down all these moments
so we had all these moments uh stashed
away from when we started to write the
script
it was really yeah it was never like a
like we've got to find a thing to do
together it was just like the idea came
we started riffing on it became funny
and then we're like maybe we should
write this and then we wrote it and was
like maybe we should try and make this
it's good and it just kind of kept like
this each step
of the way just kept happening like that
by the way like
and let's try to make it and then we did
yeah yeah yeah of course there was
from the let's try to make it to it
getting made you know
help two years happened um yeah
i was gonna say you guys make the
process sound lovelier than maybe i've
ever heard it described
it just came up with a fun idea this is
a total tangent but it's
me it's making me think that like the
next dating reality show out there
should be challenging people to go
make movies how has
netflix not done that at this point
project green light blind date yeah
i would genuinely watch that though
definitely
so we could be the judges and celine and
logan are they
very they're they're married and they're
direct together we all need to like call
our contacts after this and
make this happen yeah yeah so sweet you
you make it sound easy of course
but what would you say was i don't know
the most challenging thing or the
biggest hurdle you got over
as far as like securing that green light
and
really feeling like you were actually
gonna make your movie
we were talking about this the other day
that if like our memory of um
the green light was never of a specific
point
it was very hazy like a green light in
the distance that
got blurrier as it got closer yeah
that's a good man um we because it's
just sort of like a funny thing
that um i don't know we we lived
in constant fear or just assumption that
it was going to fall apart at every
moment so
yeah you know you got you get cast
involved and then you're trying to get
some financing and like there's
companies that are interested and then
they want to change this or that and
they drop off and we went through you
know a bit of a roller coaster of that
already so by the time we met keshet who
did
they were the first um financing in
and found the rest of the financing for
us um they
you know we were just kind of like oh
yeah yeah yeah sure yeah
yeah we'll believe it when we're on set
um but it was just kind of
yeah like that that you know you never
quite exactly know
when it's definitely a a solid thing
inside alex and i never really
celebrated until we honestly until the
last days post
yeah and then we were all of a sudden
just had this feeling of like oh
we actually did it we actually made a
movie there's just so many things that
can go wrong in the process you know
there's so many points that you can fail
because
it's a very complicated thing with many
moving parts many people involved and
and even if it doesn't fail in one big
swoop it could fail incrementally
yeah throughout and just end up getting
like slightly not what you
really wanted to make at all so we were
just like all right you guys stick to
this
yeah and then but yeah when when post
finished
that last day that we like left the
final sound
next day and we just walked we were in
williamsburg it was raining straight it
was raining
we landed at a bar which wasn't even
open yet yeah
that he let us in thankfully because it
was raining outside and really
i think we just finished our movie yeah
i think we ordered some champagne and it
was right
i feel like that bar deserves a special
thanks in the credits yeah absolutely
did you guys have the ultimate wrap
party when you got to sundance then
oh yeah we danced so hard yeah we did
also so many of the crew came to
sundance which was really cool
and two of them were like volunteers at
sundance we had like the best
crew of all three oh no jesse was it was
number
three angelo yeah angela yeah and yes
yeah not jessie anyway three three oh
and zach and cassidy yeah three of our
i'm grateful to the volunteers every
time we go to exactly yes
i think about it every time i mean yeah
it was that was
a really fun thing at sundance actually
like chatting with the volunteers
and there was there was a screening that
a lot of them came to
in salt lake city and yeah it was nice
yeah
we had a great party with everybody like
the first night of sundance and every
like all the
crew who had come were there and even
like some of the financiers we'd never
met were there and
yeah jonathan and uh the crew and the
family like
our families yeah and then and on the
shoot it was like a it was like a
like summer camp or something like we
were all upstate
and everybody was like really happy to
be there we had just like
just great everybody was great great
vibe yeah i just try not to say the word
five
uh and john john and sunitha uh like
also like
just like loved like everybody loved
each other so they were the crew and
john and saint were hanging out like
every night and every weekend like and
there were activities it was
it was really nice so by the time
sundance came around we hadn't seen each
other in six months
um and it was just like really yeah we
did that
it was fun have you guys been to
sundance before
or was that like your grand debut um
not with a movie we'd been the year
before was it two years
prior because alex did um the sundance
labs for the screenwriters
with another project and then that
happens just before the festival so
he stayed the best one i met him there
um so we were there when like sorry
about it was playing and i
right i missed it because i was not a
half hour early for the thing
so we learned our lesson on how you get
today we learned how to
navigate sundance but yeah thank god we
did have a bit of a sundance experience
beforehand because it is
as you guys know very overwhelming and
kind of
hard to navigate so we're happy that we
you know we at least sort of knew the
lay of the land of main street and
and how to how to see a movie yeah
sort of a side question off that real
quick was did you guys
since you did know the lay of the land a
bit were you able to sneak in
any movies and did you see anything you
would recommend
yeah we did i think we saw six movies in
the end it was
difficult because but only we would
stand for the whole week
we couldn't see anything for the first
weekend because our we had too much
stuff to do for our own movie um i loved
summer time
this year yeah um alice's movie carlos
lopez
movies did you see it yes it was such a
joy
it's so different and i walked in having
made so many assumptions about why it
probably wasn't going to be for me and
yes neatly for me wrong yeah it was just
beautiful so
funny and we cried so much watching that
movie
what else did we say but i think we oh
we saw kajillionaire that was obviously
awesome as a highlight um what else did
we say i
i mean i'm sure that was 10 years ago so
we can't yeah
it feels like it yeah
so how did you come to work with sue on
this because i know you wrote the role
for her
so when did it click that she had to be
your lead
for us from the beginning yeah we we
kind of we wrote it with her in mind
hoping that she would want to do it
she's a friend
so we had to like it's kind of it's kind
of like a
it was our first movie and we were kind
of like
we're writing it for her and i hope she
wants to do it like
if she doesn't want to find somebody
else uh we didn't show it to her
um for a while though we didn't tell her
that we wrote it for her
until after we're going to shoot
because we don't want to put too much
pressure on her it was just like okay
well if you like this you'll you know
do it if you want to but we don't want
to make you feel like you have to do it
but uh we um yeah we definitely i think
it's probably maybe like third or fourth
draft
that we shared it with her and she i
think she knew that we were writing a
movie
like our friends you know except
everyone kind of knows
what you're up to a little bit um but i
i guess she didn't know that we were
gonna
ask her but i i think she was happy to
be asked
and and i i've like worked with nathan a
lot over the years
like we went we met in college like 15
years ago uh freshman year and then
just been trying to work with her and
and all the comedy people from emerson
are
really talented and uh she's she's one
of the she's one of them and then
just we've been making movies we made a
movie called snowy bing bongs together
which is
uh her comedy dance troupe it was like
an adaptation that my friend rachel and
i made
uh and that we just tried and every
opportunity to work together
yeah i'm pretty sure i just called her
by her character's name so you guys did
a really good job writing a role from
her
also i mean i feel like that's probably
exploding behind the scenes because i
know thad went to emerson too
oh really yeah awesome oh hang on that
did we meet you at sundance were you
there
i remember the resurrection yeah yeah i
remember like in that interview
we i think we had them like panned to
you
yes yes that's right that's right
i very much remember this right now
after that
i think i was in the corner like with my
headphones on where you're going oh you
were there too
i was like somewhere in the corner yeah
that's great that's funny
that was insane times it was wild it was
it was a good trip that i'm glad we went
on now that we're
stuck yes yeah yeah we'll get back we'll
get back
so you write this role for sunita and
then
you guys were telling me last time that
eventually you wound up
tailoring the jackroll to john so what
are
the different i guess like tools and
methods you have to use to
write a role for each of them what's
like the differ different thing that
each of them requires
well i think um once we knew that it was
going to be john like once we had
approached him and and talked to him and
he he liked the script and he was
excited about working with sunita
um i think that's when we were like okay
we've got someone who's like such an
incredible
physical actor and i think we sort of
started catering the script a little bit
more towards like what's going to be
really physically funny to see
jack do um because he's very tall
he's like very lanky as his big
expressive hands and um so just we just
knew that it was gonna
like the more that we could do kind of
physically there so
definitely once we knew we had both of
them i think things started tweaking to
be
a bit more like like big and silly in
that way
um because it would just be stupid to
not take advantage of that i guess
um and then it's just like little things
we had a few
script conversations with them and in
our rehearsal period it's just
you know kind of them giving us feedback
on what
feels weird coming out of their mouths
or whatever and and how to kind of like
adapt the script a little bit how the
relationship how the relationship
clicked like
they had a couple notes on that which
really helped so like before the
we started shooting we made some like
really minor adjustments that sort of
set
made them a little more real and and it
was all it's all just like these
like micro tweaks that you and then once
they're actually saying the dialogue
they're a little
loose with the exact wording and stuff
they you know
yeah they have to make it feel real yeah
this movie has such like a
pure tone like a positive lovely energy
is that something that they were able to
pick up in on the script
right away i just feel like a lot of um
these types of movies might be snarkier
was that ever something you had to
finesse out
we talked about that every step of the
way actually that was like a
really important thing to us like from
when
you know we wrote the first draft of the
script and had people read it
like just you know checking in did you
did you feel like you liked these
characters or were you do you feel like
we were making fun of them and
that was very important to us to for it
to not just be
like these typical like shitty hipsters
that we were making fun of that but
you know they they are kind of shitty
hipsters but they're also
just like us and just like our friends
and and i think
our idea was that if we made them sort
of lovable
and relatable then you'd be a little bit
more invested in the journey
with them rather i think that the making
fun of hipster's joke would have
gotten tired pretty quickly yeah would
have yeah exactly and
it's funny like if you were to record
yourself and your friends
all the time there's you say we say dumb
[ __ ] all the time you know what i mean
like
and if you record it it could be laugh
out loud funny literally
lives yeah but we um
it's embarrassing we talked about that
definitely with them like getting that
tonally right
and that was no big note to it yeah they
they really felt the same way they were
like
this feels like a little mean and i
don't want to be mean to my partner this
is like a little like little
things like that that we talked to um so
there was that and then
you know again in the edit we we
finessed that even further there was
just like
it was not even so much like them like
mean spirited or whatever but it was at
a point
just dialing in up and down the
goofiness you know just
like allowing them to have some goofy
moments but not
too too many so that you didn't kind of
lose them into cartoon land
our editor sophie marshall was like like
at one point she was like
we've earned this goofy moment yeah that
was great
i can't remember what that was but yeah
she's like
pull back here pull back here and then
you can go right there yeah
so now for your other characters in the
movie why poofs
and did you ever toy around with any
other alien
designs yeah
this is a proof that a prototype no no
production designer katie made this for
us
i feel like legit manufacturing sell
those
we'll talk to katie about it um
there was never another idea i mean
aside from like when we were very very
early stages of like throwing around
ideas but we were stoned one
night which we don't do very often this
is just like a kind of special occasion
yeah exactly um we were like
what if there was like it was like two
aliens that they thought they were one
thing
and i mean it was just like studios or
stuff like that
but um but when we came up with the
poops it it definitely like stuck
and um and yeah there was a version of
the script where the where the
early on we were like maybe the proofs
could bring them back into their
spaceship
and uh show them around and be like what
do you think of that that was decor
yeah that was not the script that was
just that was pretty scripted we didn't
write that down
yeah the poops just obviously came out
of you know wanting
it to be something that could be in the
cabin for a while before they realized
that it was
an alien or you know just not furniture
what could look like a piece of
furniture
and an alien yeah um
just right away
[Music]
um yeah i think yeah i mean you could
put your feet up on it but
risky before it happens yeah
yeah we yeah we once we sort of like got
going with the
proof idea it became very fun and and
also like
it became like you know just all of a
sudden this fun sort of throwback
creature movie and it's you know
obviously referential of
critters and tribbles and and things
like that which was exciting to us that
it could
be something that lends itself to a
practical
approach yeah like growing up with those
movies and then and then
like getting like being able to do those
practical effects and having having
something that feels like it's in the
it's the same family a little bit was
was like a real appeal for us
and and even though it's funny because
it looks it looks like a more like a
tribble or a critter but it like
the way we sh the biggest inspiration
for how it moved
was the facehugger from aliens it was
like that that was like
like the tricks that they use in that
that's like what we studied to
to make the proof move whereas tribbles
you could just
just hold them and drop them earlier
like make somebody like drop a bunch of
them from out of screen
what about uh so we are going to move on
to spoilers soon
let me know how much more non-spoiler
stuff you have before we pull that
trigger but
i want to know about the the cabin
location
where where did you wind up finding that
because i feel like movie or not there's
just something like
stunning and very visual appeal visually
appealing about how that whole house is
set up and everything in it
yes we were so lucky we lucked out
because uh
we are we had a location scout uh jesse
and he found it and uh it was the first
place we saw in a two-day scout
we were just blown away one first of all
it's like
it's cinematic like you put a camera on
it and you're you're
you're good to go it's got the interior
design is like
it is very like we're all we're in that
cabin so much so it's like there's
different looks for each wall and
and our uh production designer even like
added a little bit of
uh texture to it and things and then you
can turn the camera certain ways and all
of a sudden like
the beams on the ceiling are like a
little more menacing and like all of a
sudden it changes and this
wall of windows that's so picturesque at
the beginning is like really scary later
because they're so vulnerable
they're just in this glass exposed house
in the middle of the night where you can
i mean really from the outside you just
see the landscape and you can just see
into all of it
um so it is pretty scary but yeah it was
not only that but it also
checked the box that had a pond it had
the barn
um and it had like a perfect amount of
space for production too which is huge
it's not
obviously the first thing you think
about you actually want the look and all
that stuff
but um but it's hugely important to an
indie film to have
a space be production friendly because
you know you
you otherwise you're just um you're
gonna lose time you know if you have to
move around too much to get to lunch or
whatever like
you lose time and we flipped it around
it was that was actually the back of the
of the cabin and the front is like it's
it's a little lower and that's where you
put the production advance and stuff so
that the driveway that they come up on
is
i'm sorry i think fedex is knocking out
her door i have to just
get this i'll keep talking about this
driveway while eleanor accepts her like
irs
package um uh so so the driveway that
they pull up on
goes to nowhere it's nothing but that we
so we just flipped the whole thing
around and it became a perfect
production
hub it was it was a miracle of elizabeth
that's good you got it i'm off of stuff
yeah you get those packages when they
come they put the slips on your doors
for the factory i ignored the first
knock i was like i know what this
is maybe it'll just go away and he
knocked again and it was like all right
we have to support the usps it's fedex
we have to support fedex yeah
all right haley should i do it do you
have anything else
i mean i feel like anything i'm going to
ask is
what i have one question that's like
spoilers it doesn't matter let's do it
let's all right
i i will tell you one thing i was very
amused by watching it again
the alexa went off once at the
at the very beginning scene and i'm like
like you did that thing where it went
off and it's like i don't understand
what you're saying
and there was full whitney houston music
blasting through my house and i kind of
loved it
yeah somebody else told us that the
other day and they said they paused
the movie just to enjoy the moment of
listening to houston for a bit which is
so funny if you have an alexa you get
whitney houston
we uh have google so we get moby dick
it starts reading moby dick to us all
throughout post
that happens i think that there's like
an
added layer of interactivity that's just
not tapping into it like it's
like choose your own adventure depending
on what product you're in
it's an easter egg it's a little scary
as i explained that
but i'm into this it's like
smell-o-vision
well it's also i think you know it goes
along with the sort of themes of the
movie and thinking about like technology
and being plugged in
and all of a sudden you're reminded in
the middle of the movie that something
is listening
all right guys for everyone out there
who has not seen
save yourselves the movie is hitting
theaters nationwide on october
2nd and then you're going to be able to
watch it on digital on october 6th so
check it out i feel like if you couldn't
already tell by this conversation haley
and i are really into it
go watch it but for everybody who has
seen the movie now you can stay
because it is spoiler time we're going
to talk about spoilers in the movie
um haley do you want to go with your
question first sure and this is like
is it spoilers i don't know let's be
safe it's not
but you guys are very specifically
uh sourdough bread making and gardening
which are like the pandemic activities
uh where did those come from and did you
get super weirded out when suddenly
everyone
on the internet was doing those two
things yeah that was
certainly weird yeah that's right jack
says i want to start a community garden
that's our community garden
we have started a somewhat of a
community garden in our
department garden we started a little
arab garden and pandemic together which
is nice um
it is weird the sourdough especially is
weird because
um we were concerned that people
wouldn't get that joke
yeah like he definitely says that he
says sourdough at some point at the
beginning
just refers to it as his starter his
starter like people aren't going to know
what this is
um
so we just went with it hoping for the
best and you know like we did obviously
test audiences and stuff and people got
it at that point
yeah everyone has at least a friend with
a sourdough starter right at this point
yeah we have we have one friend of the
sourdough now we have like
50 fans with the sound of starter we
have still personally avoided
sourdough starter ourselves we have not
gone down that road
but i started making kombucha a couple
weeks ago
so alex is now one of those guys
what did it cost today i just started
drinking kombucha
during lockdown for like extra energy
and health
reasons but they have run out of my
kombucha at the store so now i can't get
it
i know where do you live wait do you
live in i forget where you live
i live in la but i've been in new york
for a very very long time now
i've never been in new york i was gonna
say we could bring some over
homemade the way it works is there's a
lot of importance mail it away
yeah we'll ship it for that flash frozen
like a fish
yeah it's like it's like it's as
disgusting as a sourdough starter it's a
little
it's like a living organism it's just
like it sits in the kitchen in
a bowl it looks like um like human
tissue like you're growing human tissue
in a jar it's disgusting um and yeah
like skin it's like covers harvesting
skin
uh we saved like you know 10 bucks a
week or whatever so
yeah from from not ultra from trinidad
it is good i have to say it's gross but
it is really tasty the hunger
stuff the one thing that was really fun
was the day that jared leto came back
oh yeah he's doing a meditation retreat
and he didn't know about the pandemic
we got a lot of texts that day yeah
that's fantastic
um i i'm going to say that i could not
keep my starter alive but i did keep a
garden alive
i don't know how that works doesn't one
seem way harder
yeah yeah where do you live are you in
la
i am in l.a yeah yeah you can keep a
nice garden in l.a
where are you are you in l.a yeah we're
in las vegas we
we uh we lived in new york for about 10
years and then moved here
right after we wrote the movie just in
time to go back it should make the movie
yeah the uh the heat wave did literally
burn some of my plants alive like now
yeah yeah but otherwise california is
lovely side rant i'm just very proud of
my garden i can't help it
i don't even know about what my plants
in la look like right now
oh no oh my cat sitter has been watering
them every so often but i feel like it's
just
not nearly enough yeah it's it's a lot
just about the the love i think that you
give them
you got to make sure that your sitter
has it's really exploded in california
so haley brought up some stuff from your
movie that's actually happening right
now i'm curious since
lockdown and all of this began have you
rethought
what your two characters kind of do in
this crate what they would have done
in this crazy situation that we like
literally are in right now
yeah yeah i mean well one thing that
we've been thinking about lately is that
when we wrote the movie
it was um it was very much about like
oh there's all these bad things
happening in the world and none of us
are really paying attention to them
because we're just like so consumed by
our phones but
in the last six months that feels like
it's taken a pretty big
shift to people really paying attention
and really caring
and doing active things to try to change
um tons of bad things that are happening
in the world so um
that seems like like a little dated now
yeah the movie became
more relevant and like less relevant
yeah
because it seems like you know they they
might jack and sue
now in 2020 they're more yeah
involved than than they are um
yeah i don't know i guess yeah i guess
if they if they knew what we know now
maybe they would be
more prepared maybe they'd have some
water you know
yeah saved somewhere or would have
brought a few more survival tools with
them upstate
yeah they definitely yeah sue would
probably organize uh
had it like um like all the things that
they need to do
uh and jack would probably dream about
far like having a farm like yeah
it's like oh now is the time we really
got to get that farm yeah
yeah they'd probably be planning to move
upstate if it was
yes yeah in 2020 not just going for a
week right
i do feel like that cabin getaway sounds
real real good right now
so what about the very end of the movie
did you always know you wanted to end it
with
with that exact same thing happening or
did you ever consider
i don't know like i guess the only way i
can describe it is maybe a more
traditional ending to a disaster movie
yeah like where they figure out what's
what what makes the proofs tick and then
they
defeat them yeah that was yeah i mean
that was always what we were trying
to not do um and yeah in terms of the
the actual ending ending that was sort
of always the plan it was yeah i
remember like when we first sat down
to start writing the script i was like i
get it all like what's going to happen
the end and alex was like well
they're going to go into space and i was
like oh yeah right
sure um but yeah i mean i think you you
explain it well it always it always
seemed like just like the
the appropriate thing to happen to these
characters like it just felt like they
they get exactly what they deserve which
is not like a violent death or anything
but it's just like
being cast into the unknown and uh
i also like we also just thought that
this um that there was just this nice
symmetry between the first scene where
you see them and this is like really
stark image of
two characters like in a bubble like
like floating through space like
completely [ __ ] you know what i mean
and then the end of the movie is
exactly the same thing just literally
they're just literally floating through
space
and into into the unknown and we and we
also like this
this like growing up um family metaphor
so like they
get they get married and then they have
a baby and then they're
like it's this great image of just like
a new family going into the unknown
which i think is what
happens when you have a baby you're just
like oh all of a sudden we have a baby
we have to keep alive and where are we
going
yeah but we um yeah i mean so that was
always like where we wanted it to end up
and then obviously like the hard part is
how you get there
um that changed a lot that changed
through through many drafts and and it
was like pretty
late draft that where it really clicked
that alex
had this idea to um that their phone
should come back on and that's how they
get trapped which we just thought was
very funny as soon as you sort of had
that idea because
they've learned so much you know
throughout the movie and they've come
together
and they've you know they've worked hard
to care for something outside of
themselves and they've you know
lost their yeah they've shed their ego
whatever they're like
we don't matter and it's like oh they've
they've found urbana in a way
and then um and then their phones come
back to life and it's just immediately
like go check twitter check facebook you
know like and then as this bubble is
growing around them
um you know and then they they get sent
into space so it's just sort of like
yeah they're very close and then of
course we all just ultimately fall back
into the trap of our phones
yeah it was a classic tragedy
did you ever think about what a save
yourself
sequel would look like both from their
perspective like they're they're off
into the unknown do they actually
arrive anywhere and what do they do but
also what is then the state of
earth being overrun by poops yeah
yeah we think about that too because i
don't think it's like earth explodes
earth goes on
it's just going to be a very like
strange and unlivable place
and there will be some humans left
behind yeah like not everyone died or
get got captured
um and so then it's like what does that
look like when you're all of a sudden on
a planet without you know assuming at
this point like all
systems of communication are broken down
you know they have to like
rebuild and learn how to you know grow
their own food and learn that 19th
century lifestyle yeah
that everyone's trying to trying to have
we have yeah we have all sorts of ideas
and like we're uh
thinking about all this for like maybe a
tv show yeah
it's fun to it's fun to think about all
this accessibilities
we thought about like when we were
writing too because it's like it's just
so much fun to think about like all
these other characters and
what their movie would be and then like
where they go and what happens to them
and
what the myth like we have like a deep
mythology for the poofs
and uh which we won't go into now
because it's really so boring to talk
about
but um but yeah you know if we ever make
anything
in the same world of save yourselves
it'd be fun to start peppering in some
of the mythology stuff
in a way that we didn't we deliberately
didn't do in the movie but i think you
know you can have an opportunity
to do that later maybe um but in terms
of where jack and sue go
we always think of that they are they
will land
on it on a planet that um you know is
uninhabitable to to humans obviously so
they have
to live inside little bubbles of
atmosphere to for themselves to be
safe there and maybe it's that somewhat
somewhat zoo-like
but um but maybe not so menacing yeah
that they they have everything they need
so they're kind of fine but
they're not really fine it's kind of
like real life yeah
get more into the uh the poof sequel
yeah
there's something you said earlier too
that it you know uh haley knows this it
kept making me think of what
uh mike dougherty did with trick or
treat and the the sam spin-offs for
different halloweens
for different uh holidays like there's
there's something about like a
animated series or a comic book that i
feel like
definitely a comic book would be awesome
a graphic novel
complimentary uh issue for the movie
just about poops would be great
yeah because from their perspective they
all have different personalities yeah
the cabin poof the brown proof that's in
their cabin has a whole story yeah
he's the most fleshed out booth for sure
do any of the individual i'm so obsessed
with them i can't help it do any of the
individual poofs have names or on set
when there were many do you just refer
to them
as all the poofs um it was just mostly
like the cabin poof the woods poof and
the roof poof were the main
ones the roof poofs when there are like
many of them on the roof there was
actually only like maybe
three or four that we filmed on the day
yeah
with what with like wires and they were
actually moving and there were like
seven puppeteers moving them and stuff
um and then you added more yeah we asked
our vfx supervisor we're like do you
think you could
make more poof the one that shoots like
shoots and sticks to this
so funny because and that that one
especially we think is so funny i mean
we're talking about
micro detail here that you probably
don't remember but
um it's very funny to us because the way
the proof sort of like lands on the roof
it kind of bounces it like it looks like
a mistake it looks very practical
because it's like why would you vfx
something in that looks like a mistake
but like it sounds like the landing yeah
it really just was like
but yeah jeff really got into the
mindset of the proofs and
and really knew how to kind of like make
them move around in a funny way
well i i'm curious you know you said you
guys had the idea of the proof
early on because it needed to be
something that could fit in the house
but um when it comes to when we finally
see like how
deadly they are what was the process of
determining
how they kill how that would look
because you certainly don't maybe expect
it to be
so fast
yeah that we we brainstormed that a lot
that
all that changed a bunch yeah i remember
the first thing was like when
the poof is in the cabin it was like
what will be a fun surprising way for it
to get
out of the cabin and so we thought of
this sort of like
you know stretchy tube suction thing
spider-man like yeah that moves around
um and so
then once we sort of thought of that as
a way that it moves
it was also like well what if that's a
way that it
kills as well drinks and does everything
so
it's the uh you know in our minds what
it is is this tube that can kind of
suction onto a thing and then
because of a proof is actually like a
basically a ball of gas
covered in little as you might have
guessed you don't understand um
we figured that it's it has an ability
to sort of like
shoot out like a high pressure air
bullet basically through anything with
with quite
precision yeah so it can you know bust
through
glass or steel or a human's body so you
mean
then sequel is what you're telling me
yeah right
it's um that the the scene on the road i
mean we just
we didn't want it to be like really gory
i guess
um of the movie but we just we knew that
we needed like a moment where you see
people
die you know you see how people get
killed to
really all of a sudden have a fear of
like oh no this is really
bad because up until that point you've
seen people
die but you haven't seen how and so it's
like maybe not as scary until that
moment
um but those yeah those the stunt people
were so good and so so i mean it was
just
such a bizarre thing to try and explain
to them like okay so the tube is gonna
stick to your head and then it's as if
it's exploding on the other side you
know like
trying to explain the process of how
a proof kills a person that they they
were just like
very on board with it and did great
deaths i thought like just
yeah it was great yeah we mostly just
wanted to keep the proof surprising
oh would you say i feel like i'm too
obsessed with all the proof backstory
now
but just because you brought this up and
also another thing earlier on in the
interview
since locked in i've gotten in the habit
of watching things that i usually
wouldn't with
with my parents and my mom watched this
with me the other day
oh wow i just like i assumed it wasn't
really going to be her thing but she was
very into it and the two things that she
said
was those two characters are so likable
and whatever it is i need to know what
happens to them and she also like i'm
flat out telling you the truth right now
she said exactly what you just did where
she likes them so much and also she felt
the threat the entire time
and like oh great combination so oh
that's a little nice
that's so nice yeah we we had a similar
feeling about like we're like this is
very specific about like you have to be
30
between 30 and 37 to like
not for me apparently yeah eleanor's 38
she's over the hill she can't she won't
like it yeah
but you turned 38 after all right all
right all right anyway your point
uh my point is at sundance this this uh
this it was a
uh like it was just one of the
volunteers wasn't she yeah volunteers
spy in their 60s like our parents age
and and then her
teenage her little older son or whatever
and she was like we both loved the movie
and she was like
you wrote this movie for me it was
really sweet she was like i
like the phone it is it is so nice like
when
yeah when many people can relate to it
because it does feel very
specifically brooklyn 30s
but um yeah it's nice it's nice to know
thank you
i hope that we're playing wait one more
proof question one more point
i swear i'll leave it alone so the poo
the poofs come to earth
if humans didn't get so riled up
do you think that they would have been
just flat out killing machines or would
they have just drank all the ethanol and
then
gone about their business interesting
question
kill i think yeah i don't think that
there was any way
around that happening i mean really the
only reason that
the cabin poof doesn't kill them is
because of the calvin puff's personal
backstory but
um we we see we like that there was this
this one proof that sort of like like
more of a pacifist
more of a did we say it's already more
of a scientist type and
it just looks looks at um you know is
observing
jack and sue and because they don't
appear to know what's going on in the
rest of the world it's this perfect
opportunity to just
watch them which is why he kills the the
other people who
you know come near the cabin the graph
and the guy in the woods
um you know who who threatened to sort
of disrupt this
this perfect uh case study yeah he
doesn't kill jack and sue and you know
and obviously when they
approach him with the tongs with the
fireplace tongs there's sort of like a
moment of okay i guess i'm getting out
of here i didn't really come here for a
fight
um but the other proofs definitely came
with a
mission most of them came with a mission
yeah we didn't have a chance
yeah like gizmo compared to the rest of
the ground ones
yeah yeah yeah all right that's right
yeah yeah well i guess now perry has
inspired another poof question from me
we're just hooked
um so like in your
mind do they go from planet to planet
like locusting up the resources oh
exactly yes they're kind of like a
weapon that's like on it it's like an
autonomous weapon
goes around haley as you said that
question i heard it in like the
independence day voice because i'm
pretty sure that's how president
whitmore explains how the aliens go from
to planet i go from planet to planet
all of my science is based on
independence day but it's
certainly same that's awesome yeah
yeah i would like i definitely am not a
science person
so for a long time i was like why
ethanol why anthony oh
they're yeah that's in everything
gas and booze yeah yeah um
well i was gonna ask jumping off of
perry's lovely mother's sentiment
um hi mommy
[Music]
you do care and you are nervous and then
you throw a baby in the mix
i'm curious to what extent you were
comfortable playing up that fear was
there a concern that once you add a baby
that maybe they feel
safe because this movie doesn't feel
like the kind of movie that's an
off a baby yeah
until they lose the baby right yeah
right we would never have done that
for sure i think there's this thing
where like i don't know when you watch a
movie you
you you know you can feel worried for
somebody and also at the same time
think like well i'm not gonna kill this
character i think like the little girl
in
aliens or something you're like oh i
really like you're really worried about
her but you're like they're not going to
kill that little girl like if you think
about it for a second
moment to moment there's like a little
bit of a disconnect yeah yeah
yeah we we wanted to like to
to make people like worried because it's
the baby's very vulnerable and then they
just leave it in the woods
and just let it go yeah i mean it's it
is
it does it feel like it adds a totally
different layer to the movie when there
is a baby especially i mean honestly
every time we were
even just in the edit of the movie every
time we would get to that scene
it was like i forgot that there was a
real baby in the movie and then
it was every time they open the car door
and the baby's there it's like oh my god
we had a real
baby in this movie it's so crazy
to just like remember that i mean you
know we shot it in the woods and we were
in like the areas of the woods that were
very close to houses it was
not as remote as it looks and there's
three of them when you see it in the
movie there's no
like there's no pretense there it's like
that is a real
living baby that they have to deal with
now and it's really terrifying to us
i'm just terrified of babies in general
so yeah yeah
yeah hi um
haley do you have any more questions
before we ask our
our big two our big two big two i
actually know
i know their answer to one of them oh
i don't know yeah i think i because i
think we talked about this when i
when i brought up my cat's go bag
i'll get this i'll get this one out of
the way first we always ask all of our
our guests do you have any pets
we do not have pets we just have a lot
of plants
but i had pets growing up i had two dogs
two cats uh two frogs a turtle
we had a lamb right a lamb at a point
grew up where did you grow up that you
had so many of those
animals um in adelaide australia just in
in the suburbs we had that many
animals but we had a sheep farm um and
occasionally like some uh some baby
sheep would get rejected by
the mother of sheeps and we would have
to take them home and
feed them from a bottle that was a
highlight of my childhood for sure
getting to quite a little baby baby lamb
so cute
it would have been a highlight for me
that was very cute all right haley you
want the next one
well yeah you can't have both
no i would not
no we always ask everybody to sort of
wrap things up um
what what have you seen or read or
played we're very open anything in the
genre sphere
doesn't have to be new it can be
something old or something new anything
you would recommend to people when they
sign off from this that they should go
check that out
the documentary thing that we've been
doing wait did you say it has to be
sci-fi though oh oh
genre genre we we do love genre but
uh it's your yeah well what have we been
watching in
i mean we have been always watching a
lot of uh we were
eleanor had never seen 12 monkeys and
that's one of my favorite movies and it
it's still very that was great we
watched another and brazil
as well that um yeah 12 monkeys is
obviously very relevant right now
because it's about
uh pandemic pandemic yeah um but you
know
it's actually about a planned democrat
yeah exactly
um that was really fun to watch um i
recommend revisiting 12 months so the
the guy who came up with tribbles for
star trek david gerald
wrote a sci-fi book called the man who
folded himself
and i read that in quarantine and it's
fantastic it's like a time travel movie
about this guy
who keeps like he just ends up like
living with versions of himself and
it gets a little uh uh he has like some
romances with himself it's like a
fantastic book
it's great i highly recommend it i also
i do want to know what documentary you
were going to say oh
it's not one documentary but we've been
doing this thing where we
watch a documentary and then immediately
follow it with the documentary now
version of that documentary yeah and
it's
so fun it's fantastic so we did the
marina abramovic one we did the song
time
documentary dreams of sushi i did
uh the war room right it's and oh the
what's the bible
oh the salesman and it'll just it's just
a great night because
you're watching these great
documentaries and then you're just like
really excited about how they're going
to get made fun of
yeah and then the you know the
documentary now version is obviously
only 30 minutes right yeah so it's not
really
true quite a double feature but um but
it's very enjoyable that's a big
wonderful idea i actually i have one uh
very special sign off question just for
you guys
do you guys now have a go bag oh yes we
do
oh good we have two earthquake kits
eleanor bought one for the house one for
the car it's you know
we bought the kit you know that has all
the important hand crank radio and all
that stuff that you need but then we've
filled it with
other things as well like clothes
contact lenses like little specific
things contact lenses you know that was
a big one
we got those in there um one is like
beside the bed
right now it used to be under a cabinet
but we
there was an earthquake the other day
yeah i was like let's keep this beside
me
but then you ran out under the under the
table and left the earthquake
i know i really failed i actually have
one more movie question that's been
on my mind i i was very impressed i told
you guys that you did the contact and
contact thing at all because that's
always something that makes me think i
have a lesser chance
during a disaster but what inspired the
bit about her eating her contacts
because i have not been able to stop
thinking about that
where you got that from like sometimes
you're just walking around and you just
like talk to yourself in your head and
it was just a conversation i had in my
own head and then i thought it was funny
and it didn't
it was it was like we just put it in we
put it in the movie and then it fit and
it worked it was just like a funny thing
you know and we think that sue really
does eat her contacts that is a
strange thing that she does but the
weird part was
there's um we were talking i remember i
can't remember if it was post production
or
in pre but um they're now production
supervisor
came up to me once and he's like i love
the bit about when she eats the contact
lenses she's like do you guys
do you guys do that i do that i do that
and i'm like
no don't need your contact lenses like
ben we don't do
like not often he just had done it in
the past i think he said like when he
was too tired to
like take them and put them in but he
just i mean it's bizarre but
um it's gotta be something people do i'm
sure there's one i'm sure there's a
reddit
yeah on this i'm surprised with how much
i've thought about it i haven't gone
down like the google rabbit hole of
trying to figure out
if it was a thing because as a contact
lens where are myself like i cannot get
out of my head i would i would
i would never have you ever held them
you're not even curious now perry oh
this is alex is
almost eaten have you ever held them in
your mouth like when they fall out of
your eye
like you're supposed to be very like
clean i'm like neuro i'm like ocd
and clean it would it would terrify me
to put in my mouth in the back of my eye
you have to you have to rinse it after
that you can't just put it straight back
in here you can't just rinse it with
water
no with contact solution it's just to
keep it moist until you can get to
contact solution
for that reason but even that bothers me
when i'm not using proper contact lens
solution
yeah yeah no it's rough it's gross and
um
very funny people really do it well now
we know what i'm googling right after
this
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with us today before we let you go do
you have any uh
social media handles that you want to
share with our our viewers they can
follow us
in your work the the movie handle is is
that save yourselves movie
and on twitter it's at save yourself
mov because the the the thing was too
long
15 characters at save yourself
yeah um yeah sunithamani and sunithamani
right john p reynolds
yeah we mostly we don't we're not as fun
though we don't have very many followers
uh but follow the movie and and tell
your friends if you if you like it
yeah yeah i'll second that thank you
guys again
yeah emily where can everyone find you
in your work oh you can find me on
twitter at haley vouch on instagram at
haystackmcgroovy and on collider
and i'm at p number off on twitter and
instagram that's it guys thank you so
much for watching
you have officially survived the
witching hour